ihre forderung fürs internet nur von
viren auf ein renditen locken probiert
jahren gemeinsam ist vielen leute die
eidgenossen und basteln gemeinsam was
wir mit dem ziel nach dem glück nicht
schlechter dastehen als vorher
das ist doch schon mal gut woher auch
immer sie das s steht für deutsches
selbst was ich so auch in der freizeit
ich muss in der politik für rumbasteln
in meiner freizeit bastelt mit meinen
zehnjährigen sohn gewesen
super dann machen wir doch was das du
mit ihm auch machen kannst wir machen
nämlich beutel auf t shirts
wir haben da auch schon einfach t shirts
vorbereitet hervorragende rohstoff zu
beutel schneiden sieht auch ein bisschen
aus wie eine warnweste 48 uhr ich bin in
der cdu voraus glaubt sich alles was ich
sage das kann sich auch noch ein
rollkragen machen wenn man gerne oben
ohne sein team trotz dem rückraum mitte
zu am strand man ja keine haus kurz auf
die extrem lange cdu statt auf links
drehen
für alle gut aber die spende als
kompromiss könnte immer noch einfach
machen entscheidungen für heteros nicht
daran hören wäre die richtige strafe für
die idee für alle
der parteitag war wieder war nämlich gut
gelaunt sie war eine irre gut drauf wie
ist denn die spd erst brauchen die gute
resultat es gar nicht mehr
wenn ich sie gar nicht mehr zu halten
komplett am ausflippen will wird das
feld vom probiert das macht ihn ganz
ruhig die wahl ist die einzige art ihn
vor einem herzinfarkt zu bewahren aber
keiner gern auch kanzler werden also ich
finde das eigentlich oft einer
sozialistischen ebene gefällt mir der
ansatz dass sie jemanden haben mit dem
man sich identifizieren kann weil die
meisten bürger werden ja nicht kanzler
gemacht dann kann man sich auch mit ihm
identifizieren
ich finde höchsten typ zum
identifizieren oder eben weil er auch
nicht wenn klar wird wie die meisten so
dass leukämie kann der das dekorieren
heute ist wenn man einkaufen geht ist
das für sie als sozialdemokrat wenn sie
sich eins von beiden aussuchen müssen
werden die er für das soziale oder für
die demokratie
wir sprechen sie im kernpunkt weil du
wirst ja demokratie an
während das unglück oder fremd
bestimmtes glück nein bei der
sozialdemokratie gehört das soziale und
das demokratische untrennbar zusammen
demokratie funktioniert nur werden die
leute auch partizipieren können wir sie
teilhaben können am ganzen und dazu
brauchen sie soziale dimension
sonst wird so der stratege was hier
eigentlich auch machen auf dem parteitag
alle happy kleine kritik nur dass man
dann die nordkorea hat nicht den fehler
macht um den wähler auch wählen zu
lassen
ich hab wie hier gewaltig machen ob man
deutlich die sie ein bisschen jünger aus
als jetzt gerade aber die lena ihr
wahnsinnig jung aus für stückl bist du
dich schon immer so marten riesenkopf
aber ein echter verfügen sorgen wie
gehören erstens sehr begabt in dem
schweizer künstler die politiker werden
sollte man ja eigentlich meiden aber
wenn sie sagen sie wollen das gar nicht
erst dann finde ich das gut
einigermaßen da brauchen wir jetzt
können wir genauso spielen
natur ist genau mein beuteschema
dabei wird der immer dünner bestimmt was
könnte man auf dessen klamotten basteln
die zu groß ich war so im zwei mann zelt
aber ein größeres wirklich gerne machen
auf einen schleim das ist doch ein neuer
trend
ärgert sie das eigentlich passiert immer
nur über tools reden müssen und mich
über mich selber ich rede gerne über
schulz das ist ein interessanter ich
bitte sie gestand finde ich das ist
werde über den menschen kann man auch
hier das ausschauen sozusagen alle
schwierigkeiten die wir persönlich
kennengelernt hatte und hat zum beispiel
noch nie ein kind geworden
das stimmt so lassen sich zu gern
überraschen einverstanden
da werde ich den wagen nicht und
stiftung aber die farbe cadmium ihren
vorschlag man vielleicht sollte man noch
daraus machen also alle motive immer
populären selbst nutze ich würde sagen
wir machen jetzt noch was damit man auch
vor die kameras vielen dank
oppermann dankeschön bekommen wie gut
war klein gedacht
[Musik]